now nato allies have put forces on
standby and sent ships and fighter jets
to bolster europe's eastern defenses and
the european union says it is ready to
impose never seen before economic
sanctions if russia invades and in
brussels eu foreign ministers want to
double assistance to ukraine with a 1.2
billion euro package the group is also
holding talks via video with u.s
secretary of state anthony blinken
around 100 000 russian troops have
amassed at ukraine's borders over recent
months but the kremlin denies plans of
an invasion
our brussels bureau chief alexandra
funhamen joins me now alexandra let's
start with that eu foreign ministers
meeting they're meeting virtually with
secretary of state blinken today of
course ukraine absolutely front and
center we just heard there they want to
provide about a billion euros in support
for ukraine what's come out of this
meeting so far
well we saw a very strong statement
issued by the eu foreign ministers
condemning what they called russia's in
continued aggressive actions and threat
against ukraine they called on russia to
the escalate to abide by international
law and also express their support for
ukraine for the country's territorial
integrity sovereignty and as you just
mentioned the european commission in
addition announced a new financial
package for ukraine to cope with the
economic
fallout of the crisis
now in the meantime nato troops have
been put on standby military hardware is
being deployed to eastern europe the u.s
is ordering families of diplomats in
kiev to leave and return home
does the west believe that a russian
attack is imminent alexandra
well
the stakes um are high and then tensions
are high and i think that everyone here
in brussels and in particular eu foreign
ministers are aware that that could be
the decisive week
with regard to the crisis with the us us
and potentially nato to present their
written responses to russia's security
demands and what we see
with nato allies deploying more troops
warships and fighter jets to eastern
ukraine we can assume that the aim here
is to strengthen their
defense posture there and of course also
to deter russia from uh attacking
ukraine making sure that russia that
there is no miscalculation that russia
knows
that there will be massive consequences
i do want to ask you a little bit about
germany there has been some criticism
that berlin is not doing enough to be a
reliable ally to ukraine particularly
with regards to deploying military
support what more can you tell us about
that
well we asked the german foreign
minister here analina berbock what her
position is because as you just
mentioned the german government has been
criticized
for what some here in brussels uh
described as an ambiguous position on
ukraine but berberk told us that
the german government is
standing with ukraine that germany is
ready to support ukraine politically
economically not to deliver defensive
weapons that is the government's policy
so far and we also ask them whether they
would be ready to evacuate
the their embassy staff from ukraine and
here once again berbock told us that
they're assessing the situation every
day trying to figure out what's
happening there but here once again she
told us that germany doesn't want to
contribute even more uncertainly for
ukraine uh so uh
they would not like to contribute to
creating more uncertainty that could
even scare off
business people in ukraine
dw's brussels bureau chief alexandra
fundament reporting from brussels thank
you very much alexandra
and our reporters in moscow and kiev
spoke to people to gouge opinions there
on the tensions between their two
countries first let's hear from people
in the ukrainian capital
i am very worried
things are not easy in our country at
this moment
but i hope the diplomats can find an
agreement and that there will be peace
in ukraine
of course i'm worried there are people
living here and they are in danger
i think nothing will happen it's just
the usual threats from the big bandit
next door
there's nothing we can do i have to work
and feed my family i don't have time to
think about what i will do if something
happens
i have friends in kiev
and i love ukraine
i'm against war
muslim a war would be pointless there
won't be one
all we see right now is an attempt
worldwide to heat up the atmosphere an
attempt by certain people to make others
believe that one side is planning to
attack the other no no
we don't want war
ukraine is a brother nation for us
so why war
this is a political fight
my presidents here and over there do
have something in their heads at least
they don't seem empty so war won't
happen
you